the dancing and the choreography by the  way too are you so good  chris christopher scott chris scott  shout out chris scott and all the choreo  team  wait which was the hardest one poof for  me the hardest  was um dancing on the side of the  building  which forever we were like how is that  gonna happen there are no harnesses  uh yeah there are no harnesses that's  fully us  no doubles in any of these numbers um  and it was yeah there's pieces of my  back  and knee and and corey's back  and you know our souls on that on that  side of the building wherever it's at  yeah um today oh my gosh  so not put all into it it's it's  incredible  everybody you have to see it want more  fun stuff  i thought so check out these videos  floating around my head  this one is really cool i'm just saying  no pressure